there are two problems with the the
first is that they that the welfare
state that they've created is not one
that can be supported in a region of
declining population in effect they're
not enough young people to support all
these old people in the style to which
the welfare state a customs them that's
the first problem the second problem is
there a series obviously of countries
that were late you know that these
countries particularly in the east in
the former Warsaw Pact block who you
know very quickly got in debt and
they're going to have to be bailed out
by the rich countries of Western Europe
and that's going to create tremendous
stresses on the system the equivalent in
after all in Europe of the subprime
crisis here in the United States is this
incredible indebtedness of countries
like the three Baltic republics like
hungry like nevermind Bulgaria and
Romania at the same time the exhaustion
of a certain financial ability of Europe
in effect to bribe people to its
geo-economic and geo cultural and
geopolitical way of thinking by
subsidies that's how Ireland and
Portugal in Spain were brought into a
different kind of cultural matrix in
Europe that's not possible there's just
not that much money around i know i
think the crisis in europe is very very
severe and I don't you know I don't
don't think the answer is it all obvious
as to how to get out of it at the same
time Europeans expect a certain level of
social safety net and it's going to be a
problem to cut that
yeah i know i'm not sure that I the
grass is always greener on the other
side of the hill but I think sometimes I
think that the the notion of many
American liberals that somehow Europe is
this paradise that if only we could be
more like them it would all be so much
better that I think is fair but there's
a fair bit of wishful thinking they're
not because I don't prefer the European
welfare state system to the American
self keepo system but but because i'm
not sure europe can afford